bonjour les slims écoles se passe-t-il
actuellement en espagne
et bien c'est une situation qui est
paradoxal parce que l'espagne est
ouverte aux touristes étrangers mais les
espagnols eux ne sont pas autorisés à
quitter leur région de résidence sauf
pour motif impérieux alors les voyageurs
européens affluent dans les zones les
plus touristiques du pays comme à madrid
en catalogne ou encore dans les îles
canaries ou les baléares les français se
pressent particulièrement dans la
capitale espagnole grâce aux nombreux
vols hebdomadaires ils sont près de
60000 avoir fait un aller-retour en
janvier et février à madrid
selon les chiffres du trafic aérien
alors les médias espagnols parlent d'un
véritable phénomène chaque semaine il
relate l'arrivée continue de ces
touristes français la police madrilène
avait déjà tiré la sonnette d'alarmé il
ya un mois face au fait illégal organisé
dans des appartements touristiques
le commissaire de la police municipale
avait déclaré je cite ce sont
principalement les français qui viennent
profiter d'une plus grande liberté dans
notre ville alors les espagnols
craignent pour la proche de latence de
pâques nouvelles arrivées encore plus
forte de touristes étrangers alors
leslie très concrètement pourquoi les
français viennent d'île en espagne et
bien les touristes français que nous
avons rencontrés à barcelone disent que
c'est une véritable respiration que si
alors fait un bien fou de sortir au
restaurant de profiter des terrasses du
soleil alors il faut savoir qu'en
espagne les restrictions varie d'une
région à une autre
prenons l'exemple du couvre-feu il
débute à 22h en catalogne et au pays
basque mais il débute à 23h à madrid et
en andalousie
donc les touristes français profitent de
ce couvre-feu tardif du côté de la
restauration
les établissements sont ouverts du matin
au soir à madrid mais en revanche il
ferme à 17 heures en catalogne
il faut également préciser que les
musées les commerces et les théâtres
sont ouverts il ya seulement des
restrictions de mobilité pour les
espagnols et elles ont été confirmées
pour les vacances de pâques les
habitants ne pourront pas quitter leur
région de résidence jusqu'à début avril
l'hymne merci beaucoup les clés pour
toutes ces précisions l'esc illies à
singla en direct de barcelone